High School Musical taught kids that
we're all in this together and it taught
Zack Efron that there's nothing better
than a big old paycheck except maybe
friendship this is how a Disney Channel
TV movie changed its star's life for
better and worse but mostly better if
you were a kid in the mid to late 2000s
or a tired parent of one there was no
escaping High School Musical the fantasy
movie about a public school with a
well-funded theater Department became an
instant sensation after its release move
over Michael Jordan there's a new
basketball star in town and his name is
Troy Bolton just call me freaky carback
boy on the evening of January 20th 2006
over 7 million televisions were tuned to
the Disney Channel for the premere
showing of High School Musical before
the movie Zack Efron had only appeared
on TV a few times but after that night
he was one of the most famous people
worldwide at least in the eyes of
9-year-olds this was the start of
something new for rron and he started
getting attention not just from casting
directors but from random people on the
street one particular moment really left
an impression when Efron met members of
a local tribe in Papua New Guinea he was
surprised to learn that his movies have
made it across the Pacific these are the
tribesman guys came up and with cell
phones and we facetimed their cousins
and their wives and people that were
living in other places that was the
event that made Eon truly reflect on the
extent of his fame fame that he wouldn't
have at all if it wasn't for High School
Musical the guy from MTV's room Raiders
just doesn't have the same ring to it my
dream girl would look just like like a
younger Catherine Zita Johns I said that
pretty much makes me a younger Michael
Douglas given that Troy bolon was East
High star basketball player and arguably
the most popular kid in school it's not
surprising that Efron was seen by some
as sort of a golden god soon after the
first film became successful Fon
appeared on multiple teen magazine
covers and the shouts of his rabid fans
grew painfully loud even Fon himself
found it a bit much and he certainly
didn't love being called a heartthrob by
the media in 2012 he told CBS Sunday
Morning morning I can't explain to you
what it's like to be a heartthrob I
don't think I'm a heartthrob I hate it
it follows you around but you don't
deserve it needless to say efim was a
little afraid to deal with the reality
of Fame as a teenager no no I'm not
afraid
just scared but nowadays it looks like
he's come to terms with being a bit of a
hunk High School Musical wouldn't be
nearly as watchable if it didn't have
students dancing on cafeteria tables or
choreographed bball routines Zack Eon
definitely shows off some solid moves
throughout the original film but there's
still room for improvement and that's
because he'd never really done it before
just like Troy he was learning to
express himself but real life isn't a
Disney movie here's the deal no one
sings at College what Efron had to get
his head in the game and learn how to
Boogie if he wanted High School Musical
to be a success he reflected to BBC
Radio 1 I didn't know how to dance
during those High School Musical movies
I was just a kid like from the street an
actor scraping by by the end of the
franchise though Efron's dancing skills
evolved from serviceable to actually
pretty damn good outside of the
surprisingly expansive High School
Musical Cinematic Universe he provided
his pops and locks and breaks and gems
to the movies hairspray and the greatest
showman what can we say the man likes to
move Zack Efron's dancers in the first
High School Musical are the real deal no
CGI or doubles necessary the same can't
be said about his voice which was dubbed
over by actor jus cely for the songs
Efron wasn't very happy about this so
when negotiations between he and Disney
began for High School Musical 2 he
wanted to be completely sure that he
wouldn't be singing into the void that's
why he made sure that his contract had a
clause stating that no one else would be
able to sing Troy's songs in 2007 he
told the Orlando Sentinel that was a
very huge point for me I had to put my
foot down and fight to get my voice on
these tracks do I seem different to you
this summer you dressed a lot better
that's for sure the demand wasn't just a
a flex of Efron's vocal muscles but a
flex of his power in the franchise could
there really be a High School Musical
without Troy Bolton producers probably
didn't think so at the time despite
their awkwardly worded attempt to spin
off on Disney plus over a decade later
with High School Musical the musical the
series yes that's really what it's
called some of your favorite actors
might tell you they do it for the love
of The Craft but at the end of the day
they go to work for the same reason you
and I do to make that sweet sweet money
in exchange for portraying Ro in the
first High schore musical efon was given
around
$100,000 that's not a massive payday in
the acting world and the fact that he
was a fresh face in a movie that never
actually made it to Cinemas probably has
something to do with it the High School
Musical 3 senior Year which was given a
theatrical release Efron got a massive
raise taking home somewhere between $3
and $5 million for his efforts cha-ching
Efron's paycheck for High School Musical
was only a stepping stone for where his
career earnings would go now he has a
net worth of roughly $25 million 250
times more than his original paycheck
don't compare it to yours or you might
start crying since High School Musical
was Zach Arron's big break some people
only saw him as nothing more than a
good-looking Disney star nowadays it's
nearly impossible to see the singing lad
basketball man from East High when you
look at Efron's muscled up physique but
back then he basically was Troy Bolton
in the case of director Adam shankman he
nearly wrote off Efron sight and scene
when the actor wanted to audition for
link Lin in Hairspray in a director's
diary for broadwayworld.com shankman
discussed how hesitant he was about
auditioning Efron because he embodied
too much of that Disney brand charm he
admitted I thought he was too Disney and
I didn't really understand what was so
special about him once I told him to
stop smiling and read the lines again
with a Little Smoke in his voice Arch
his eyebrow and give me a wink when he
met me I suddenly knew I'd found my link
perhaps you'd like to share with the
rest of the class Patrick Henry's
Immortal Last
Words kiss my ass being typ cast as a
Disney Channel character sounds like
hell on Earth for a maturing child star
but luckily shankman was able to see
past the lingering stench of mouse and
give Efron a chance like many former
child stars Zack Efron encountered a
number of challenges as he became an
adult and many of his most important
memories from that time took place
during the production of High School
Musical as Troy Bolton grew up so did
Efron and ever since the actors escaped
from the Disney machine he's had the
time to reflect on his iconic trilogy so
what does High School Musical mean then
to Efron it's an experience he'll never
forget it's a group of friends he'll
always treasure and yes it's a whole lot
of money he told BBC Radio 1 we were
just friends doing what we loved and I
believe that was my affirmation if it's
this much fun and people like it that
much you must be providing them some
sort of service almost every teenage
service job is utterly Soul crushing but
this is the one exception Efron isn't
afraid to express his love for the cast
crew and fans of High School Musical
even though he res entered his East High
experience for a little while he's since
come to terms with how he rose to fame
cuz once a wild
cat always a wild cat Zack Efron isn't
exactly a teen heart throb anymore he's
a mid-30s heart throb Efron has reworked
His Image over the years by playing real
life characters and hosting his own
travel show but even though he once
portrayed serial killer Ted Bundy he's
still that same kid who sang about
soaring and flying whenever Efron is on
the set of some of his big boy movies
his co-stars aren't afraid to poke fun
at his Disney Channel days drawing a Q&A
for the wrestling biopic the ironclaw
Efron and his co-star Stanley Simons
revealed that Simons would sing songs
from High School Musical to the former
Child Star during the Productions
downtime he joked I sung some of
Breaking Free to Zach when I was playing
my music scene that was definitely a
life experience that I'll never forget
Simons who watched their fun from TV as
a kid simply couldn't resist the
opportunity to goof around Eon admitted
he was sort of caught off guard but
found it fun and Simon revealed Efron
coached him on how to sing it better
sadly the ironclaw doesn't feature the
pair harmonizing to start of something
new we'll just have to wait for the
deleted
scenes